partout où l'on pose son regard à
saint-ferdinand et les environs elles
sont là cinquante éoliennes au total
imposante et bruyante de plusieurs
propriétés lac sont encerclés et puis
qui sont écrasés là par les éoliennes
qui sont construites sur les crêtes des
collines
alors ça c'est vraiment un changement
dans le cadre de vie c'est une
altération gravelotte de ton milieu de
vie claude charron on a une bonne
dizaine autour de sa maison dont une à
un kilomètre lors l'envoi 3 selon les
indiens mais il ya un autre il y en a 4
août un petit peu plus loin là bas et en
tuant les enfants denise la vertu est
une fille du pays installée sur la terre
de son père elle a voulu s'en aller
quand les éoliennes ont été érigés en
dessus une fois qu'elle projette est
bien enclenché non ça le change est
vraiment ma qualité de vie au niveau de
nos s'arrête que du sont surtout moi que
je trouve vraiment le sag récent mais
pas facile de déménager cette maison est
sur le marché depuis cinq ans les
propriétaires ont dû baisser leurs prix
les résidents de saint ferdinand
estiment que leurs propriétés ont été
dévalués de 30%
ce couple veut rester même si de leur
terrasse la vue est altérée par une
dizaine d'éoliennes
ils réclament compensation pour tout ce
qu'ils ont vécu
quand on prend quelque chose à quelqu'un
on redonne quelque chose ça c'est sûr
que je restais avec sont un peu sur le
cas parce que ce soit de l'argent
n'importe quoi mais on a senti qu'on
s'est fait prendre quelque chose
la cause est entendue ces jours ci au
palais de justice de victoriaville
les plaignants veulent signifier au
gouvernement que ce projet d'éoliennes
était inutile au départ et coûteux on
n'a pas besoin d'énergie éolienne puis
ce projet en particulier côte aux
citoyens peut-être 30 millions par année
en perte en pure perte l'an à cause du
coût excessif
il est à 12 cents du kilowattheure alors
que notre facture d'électricité c'est
peut-être 5 610 kg tard on paye alors
l'or dont la peau a besoin plus ce parc
éolien devrait contribuer au
développement régional
on nous avait promis 25 emplois au bout
du compte ça ne crée environ 5 à 6
emplois
quant aux redevances elles sont minimes
juste pour saint ferdinand ses 115
milliards à 115 mille dards pour saint
ferdinand ça représente un ennemi pour
cent du budget environ alors là c'est
pour ça qu'il faut faire baisser le le
compte de taxes il ya quand même des
résidents qui ont accepté des éoliennes
sur leur terrain moyennant
dédommagements mais la majorité d'entre
eux ne vise pas sur place ce qui a
contribué à la grogne locales en général
les gens sont friands de ces chers voire
au départ je vous dirais la fracture est
toutefois bien réelle à saint-ferdinand
et prendra du temps à se résorber
ici catherine kovacs radio-canada dans
la mrc de l'érable